i know it's infuriating when anyone
presents both sides of an issue and says
let the audience decide and i don't
really like doing meta stuff where i
talk about the process of making videos
but i can't find any other way to give
enough context to make this video work
hence the come for a walk with me
through a rough bit of the english
countryside gopro camera shot it's
important to break the format visually
as well
i've been sharing videos from around
germany austria and switzerland over the
past couple of weeks
one of the first things i filmed on that
trip was the radon tunnel the radon
stolen in bad croissant in southwest
germany the video should have gone out
weeks ago but despite filming going
really well on location despite being
really happy with my script and the
interview at the time
i just
wasn't comfortable with it when i got
back here to the uk
radon or radon if you german is a
colorless odorless radioactive gas
that's produced naturally by uranium
decay all around the world tiny tiny
amounts of it seep out from wide areas
of the ground and get diluted into the
atmosphere harmlessly but if your house
is in a particularly bad radon area like
here in oxfordshire then you can get
detectors installed or tests done to
check that radon isn't building up
inside your house and exposing you to
too much radiation
which is why i was surprised that there
are a few places in the world where
people go to be exposed to radon
deliberately for pain relief
so the radon tunnel in bad cried
kreutzner it is a tunnel that was
founded 1775.
people tried to find mercury here they
dig for mercury they did never find
mercury but
around about 110 years ago they found
radon the doses is
per one hour treatment between 30 and 60
000 becquerel
in average you need 10 treatments one
hour at the end the application will
have a doses of around about 2.2
millisievert to give you an idea what is
equivalent if you have for instance
x-rays with your hip or your knee
it is more or less the same equivalent a
complete ct of the complete body has
about between 20 and 40 millisieverts
every medically trained person that i've
talked to about radon therapy they've
all gone through the same three stages
that i did first of all complete
skepticism full oh that sounds like a
bad idea
certainly most of the world would
consider deliberate exposure to
radioactive gas for pain relief as
alternative medicine that's what i did
and then stage two you look at the
scientific papers and yes the marketing
that talk about what limited trials
there have been and the patient
testimonials and the theories about why
it works and the reaction becomes oh
and
i get i guess maybe it's worth a look
but there's a conflict of interest
declaration in that paper
but it says the funders had no say in
the results or the release and there is
almost a folk belief in some parts of
the nuclear industry particularly in the
us about something called radiation
hormesis
where very small doses of radiation can
have a beneficial effect they think
because they cause repair systems in
your body to kick into action
but that is an idea a hypothesis it's
not even really a theory yet it's not
been properly tested all the major
international authorities say that it's
entirely unproven and there isn't really
any truly safe dose of radiation
and yet radon therapy seems to work for
a lot of people
so then you reach the third stage
not knowing how to even talk about this
responsibly that's where i'm at i've met
the people who run a radon tunnel i've
talked to a patient i've got a duty of
care to them as i do to anyone i film
with but i also have a duty to the
audience and to the truth scientifical
historical or personal
so i need to make something very clear
this is not an endorsement i think radon
therapy is fascinating the people who
run the raid on spa definitely think it
works certainly most of their patients
do
there's just enough evidence here this
unqualified skeptic can't write it off
not immediately
and the fact that there's all this
infrastructure for handling radioactive
gas as part of something that most of
the world hasn't even heard of
well i think that's interesting enough
to at least discuss
just to make clear it is not wellness
it's not miracle we do not promise
something weird it is pure medicine it's
a medical application where you need a
doctor's prescription
and at the end 85 of the patients they
report it helped it worked so you get
rid of your
medication for pain relievers for one
year and more
it is uh
not wellness that's a
really must be clear
obviously to get a license for this this
is uh especially in germany a really
huge and complicated process and
therefore we have to prove that the
minimum
application of the doses is not below 30
000 back a rail and the maximum dose is
never above 100 thousand becquerel we
are always in the average uh somewhere
between uh thirty and sixty thousand
which is the perfect range for the
treatment there are plenty of doctors
and health insurance companies in
germany that endorse radon therapy but
that isn't evidence for it working the
british national health service paid for
some homeopathic treatments until 2017
despite a mountain of evidence proving
that homeopathy does absolutely nothing
homeopathy may feel like it works for
some people but if you just give people
a sugar pill a placebo and say oh to
help with your pain
a lot of the time feels like it does
help at least for the short term the
placebo effect isn't quite as magical as
some folks think but
certainly very powerful for sensations
like pain and nausea the sort of things
that radon therapy is intended to treat
but the trouble is that radon spas
aren't like homeopathy or like magnet
therapy they're not popular enough to
have been comprehensively tested
anecdotes are not evidence for something
medical particularly when radiation is
involved
the warning signs of quackery of fake
medicine are bold claims about miracle
cures
single interventions that claim to help
wildly different conditions
or explanations that defy the laws of
physics it's not guaranteed to be
quackery if you've got those of course
but those are the warning signs in other
parts of the world radon therapy is much
less regulated in montana usa there are
old raid unfilled mines that just charge
admission to go sit inside and some of
them make wild claims about helping
diabetes gout asthma ms
or even cancer
but the claims made in germany are much
more limited and specific it's just for
relief of chronic pain
and the cause of chronic pain can often
be a mystery
and so can how to treat it
the the treatment doesn't work instantly
so if you leave the tunnel you are not
instantly cured patients they report to
us normally it takes some days up to six
eight weeks when it works we are aware
that some other tunnels worldwide they
claim they can cure anything
we are pain relief pain relief from
inflammatory process not more and not
less so normally people think
radioactivity oh that's harmful
but it is always the same question is
the doses that makes sense and
what we hear apply you see this
equipment that is monitoring how much uh
radon is emitted and we do emit radon in
that
quantity that is necessary to uh
initiate healing processes there's one
line in that big analysis paper that
says it's really difficult to do a fully
double-blind study about this that would
be where each patient doesn't know if
they're receiving radon or not and
neither do the staff or the doctors yes
radon is colorless and odorless but it's
always there coming out the ground you
can't fool people into walking into a
somehow identical tunnel or cabin that
you've just mysteriously constructed
next door to the old one but doesn't
happen to have raid on it at this time
except in that one tunnel in bad
croissant you can turn off the radon
this is absolutely unique and to my
knowledge no other tunnel worldwide has
the same technique and that is why we
are today absolutely safe as you see on
the monitor we have no radioactivity
here besides the normal activity you
have outside the red on gas is emitted
very deep down
in that
mountain and it is naturally emitted
at the end we just
grab the gas with with a pipeline and a
kind of fan that transports it into this
room and we can switch it on and off in
that
proportion we need it that's why i was
allowed to film in the treatment room it
didn't have any raid on it it's not then
anyway it hadn't been used for hours all
the ventilation meant there was just
fresh air in there it would absolutely
be possible to set up a proper
large-scale double-blind study in that
tunnel if some university or government
wanted to fund it if they could find
enough willing patients if their ethics
review board would be willing to sign
off on treating people with radioactive
gas
and if it could be arranged that no one
not even the staff at the tunnel
knew whether each patient was getting
radon therapy or just fresh air it would
be difficult but it's more possible
there than anywhere else and i want that
trial to happen that's why i decided to
talk about this and put the video out
that's why i am willing to risk giving
an audience to something that isn't
proven yet because if that works as
claimed even just for some people with
chronic pain it's be brilliant
very minor radiation exposure is a risk
that a lot of people would be willing to
take clearly are willing to take
if they can't get pain relief any other
way
and if it doesn't work
then we probably need to stop exposing
people to radiation
i know it's a cop out to say more
studies are required it's the weak
ending to every inconclusive
undergraduate paper
but in this case it's true more studies
are required and hopefully
those studies will happen soon because i
would love to go back to a radon spa in
a few years time
and follow up with the proof
you